your kids are older they're adults did
you deal with you and kevin with the
empty nesting
syndrome totally i mean i think it's so
funny it's like you birth these children
and like yeah they're everything they're
everything for so many years they're
like the thing you think about in the
morning and the thing you think about
you know when you go to sleep at night
and like
you know you give everything you
possibly can
to like you know to give them a good
life and then they leave i mean that's
really the thing it's like
it's like you're not doing a job well
they leave if you've done your job
correctly you're
fired or furloughed i mean yeah i know
it's kind of hard but it's kind of true
and like but then
there's this thing of like but how are
you you know
in your children's adult lives you know
and i think that a lot of us
are figuring out like how do we how do
we
do that dance of like we know they're
independent but we've got some thoughts
but we don't want to interfere but we've
got some thoughts
you know what i mean it's like it's like
this dance and
uh it's it's really fun and it's really
funny
and and really relatable so are you like
always in their face okay so i'm i have
two kids too when they're teenagers
right now and i'm not in that world yet
and when you're talking i'm getting the
chills the idea of leaving but
so do you call them often do they call
you often are you in their face
you know i i really try not to be in
their face because i think that's the
key to
like i mean nothing would be worse than
to be like
overly on them i think that would just
make them like run screaming in the
other direction
um so i think that i try to you know
play it cool and uh you know wait for
them to call me
but i do call and check in like the last
time i i called my son yesterday to just
sort of say like how are you feeling
like the world is pretty crazy right now
how are you feeling and then my daughter
you know they they are they are in touch
with us like we're really lucky like we
didn't get fired and like
you know deleted out of the picture
but but honestly i think a lot i think
the key to that is to like
zip your lip a lot of the time you know
and not offer like
unsolicited you know advice and and all
those things and
and gene is like constantly trying to
like figure it out and figure out what
the dance is and it's like you got you
love her so much because she's like
stumbling around and messing up
and like you know it's just it's
it's very endearing did you get a dog
you have a dog
named lily did you get the dog after the
kids left
oh no we've had dogs their their whole
lives and our whole lives
no we had lily when they were teenagers
yeah we've
we've had we have lots of animals we
always have yeah
yeah it's not a bad plan to get an
animal when you're
kids yeah and you celebrate your
anniversary
during this pandemic did you get a
chance to actually celebrate
yeah i mean for sure you know i it was
funny because
uh usually we go out to dinner you know
and instead we made dinner um but we
don't usually get each other presents
and um for our uh our
um anniversary and this year kevin
you know said i got you something and i
was like my first my first thought was
oh yeah i thought we weren't gonna get
each other or anything
i got you nothing how about this pillow
um but then he said to me
he's just walking me down to like this
little barn that we have in connecticut
and he's like
i'm like where are we going and i smell
poop
and what's happening like he gifted me
two
pygmy goats that are like
absolutely freaking adorable and like
every time you walk in and they are kids
by the way
but they're adorable because like when
you go in to see a goat like they're
really happy to see you and they like
kiss you and like are all it's just the
most adorable present ever
oh yeah i noticed like on your social
media you guys are singing through
isolation he has his guitar
he's got the goats running how are you
doing have you learned anything new
about each other or yourself just being
in this moment i mean
to be still is a different experience oh
my god it really is
i mean i think that i i god that's so
so so true i think being still is weird
and not having distractions
and like having to you know be with one
person and not be able to
you know do ever you know just being
really locked
down um i think that one you know the
amazing
thing is that i still like to hang out
with him you know i mean i just don't
think you have any way of knowing
what it's going to be like to be 24 7
with one person i just don't think you
have anything yeah
yeah and especially it's not like you
know there's great things going on out
in the world it's like there's a really
you know tough thing happening
and and we just were lucky we kind of
came together and like
wanted to hang out with each other and
still have stuff to talk about so
i think that was kind of the most
surprising thing is that yeah this
really is a good thing you know
we're definitely not getting divorced
anytime soon and
you know and in fact you know we've
actually really enjoyed each other's
company
you guys really do have a special
relationship eh
we're lucky we're really lucky we got
lucky really early on i you know i say
that like
i was i know i wasn't smart at 23 but
like
i was someone must have been having my
back you know
making me smart you know oh i love
that and you were on jimmy kimmel
talking about corona rules
are they still in place i think one of
them was
making your bed every morning girl you
making bed every morning good for you
you still do it why
oh my god that is so funny to me it's
like who knows what's gonna
go in your bed if you don't make it and
close it
up
and think wow you know i know no one
else has been here no creatures have
been here
no like you know whatever i just want to
know that like
it's closed and then i open it and
nothing has happened in the 10 hours
um yes that rule definitely sustains and
and also cake for breakfast you know i i
like just made another pound cake
you know to me it's like really
a good thing it's very soothing it's
very loving it's like an
it's like a great thing to do for
yourself and it's we're in the middle of
a freaking pandemic like
you get cake sweetie you get cake for
breakfast and we're getting cake with
your new show call your mother i
can't wait for this show i think it's
gonna be so much fun for everyone to
watch and
uh what would you say um the journey
fans will go through watching you
in this show god you know i think
they're just gonna fall in love i mean i
think you have to make people fall in
love with you in the first episode and i
think that
i mean it's always been a mandate for me
since i started doing
tv because i started in film and then
when i started doing tv i'm like you
better relate to her
like you better relate to these two like
they have
who are fumbling through life and
messing up all over the place and like
we
have to be relatable if we're going to
be in someone's living room and i'm not
interested in playing some like
elusive character that people can't
relate to like that's what you get with
me
you know and that's what you get with
this character and it's really funny